Film Courage: How does film negotiation work?
Glen Reynolds, Founder of Circus Road
Films: Usually if a distributor wants a film
they'll reach out with terms. Everybody does
it a little bit differently. Some people
will poke at me and say “Well what do you want?”
Some will just send me an email saying “Okay
here's what we would do for the film, here's
the distribution fee,” and then either they have
a a term sheet or they just type it into an email.
Usually the next step is I
present that to my filmmaker,
explain the company to them and what they're
about, introduce them so they can hear from
the horse's mouth so the distributor can tell them
exactly what they're going to do with the film and
how much they like the film, etc. Then we repeat
that process with any other offers coming in
and then I usually try to help the client make
a decision in terms of which way they want to go
and then depending on which way they want to go
there are some distributors that have come at us
exactly where they want to be and I just know
from experience there's no negotiation they've
come at me with the lowest distribution fee they
ever offer the lowest cap on expenses they'll do
the lowest term they'll do and and then there
are some companies I know that they've come at
me a little higher than what they'll do and
I know what the wiggle room is ahead of time
and so depending on who the client is chosen
I'll tell them okay well here's where I think
we can move the contract on this if they
give me the green light then I usually call
the distributor and say hey here's they like
you best but only if you can make these terms
and then if they agree then we're good and we go
to a long form and then there's a long form to
negotiate as well but usually I've seen most
of the long forms for all the companies that
I've dealt with and some of them I've redlined
before and already got a pound of Flesh and I
know exactly what they're going to what they're
going to agree to or not so there really is no
need to get into that in order to make the deal we
can just make a deal based on the deal memo or the
email and then and then worry about the long
form after the fact and if they don't come if
they don't agree to whatever I'm proffering in
terms of a counter I go back to the client say
well they wouldn't go down do you want to you
want to try them again or you want to respond
to their counter to our counter or do you want to
go given that do you want to try the other person
because maybe they're more amenable and maybe you
like them more now that you've heard that they
won't do what you want to do and so then I'll go
and but usually only negotiate with one at a time
it's just you don't negotiate with two entities
at the same time because if they both accept you
if you give them if you counter both of them they
both said yes then you've you've committed fraud
so you don't want to do that it's the only deal
with one at a time until there's an acceptance
of an offer then you then you have a deal and
sorry a term sheet is what a term sheet usually
is just a either piece of paper or a PDF that
has the basic terms of an agreement not all the
language of the agreement so it'll spell out
usually a term sheet will have the length of
the contract the rights the maybe not all
the like it'll say video on demand rights
DVD and Blu-ray rights advertising video on demand
rights it's what rights they're taking but it
won't have a description of each right which will
be in the long form agreement it'll have the term
it'll have the if there's a minimum guarantee
that they're going to pay against the rights
against against the revenues then that'll be in
the term sheet and then beyond the major things
the depending on the distributor they might have
how the just a quick couple lines on how
they do accounting a quick quick couple
lines on expenses and whether they cap them
or not and so there might be a couple things
to flesh out in the term sheet depending on
how specific or or not specific term sheet is
before we go to long form to make sure okay we
don't want to agree to this because there's a
little ambiguity in the term sheet in terms of
like accounting rights so let's be sure that what
we mean here is quarterly for two years not just
or quarterly for the whole time or what you want
to be as specific as possible before you say yes
but some of that I already know because I've seen
their long forms before so we can we can work off
just the basic terms in order to make it a deal
so it's almost like a cliff notes yeah for the
okay and then the long form is is how many pages
usually it depends on the distributor some it can
be five or six pages some it can be 26 30 pages
some of them have agreements where they have kind
of the basic terms in the first three or four
pages and then what's called the standard terms
and conditions document that's kind of stapled
to it that kind of gets into the nitty-gritty of
everything defining all the terms defining all
the rights and all those things so it depends
it depends on the company to a certain degree
how lengthy it is and what what is the usual the
standard length of term or does it vary depending
on it does vary the the range is 3 to 15. oh Years
Years you do you do see 20 even from bigger deals
but they're plunking down a lot of money
they're really making it their film
I would say most of my deals are in the seven
year range usually we're negotiating down from
15 to 7. but then there are a couple companies
that are more aggressive and do like three years
but you find that all companies have an
executive there that's like well we never
do below three years or we never do below seven
it had their own standard that they just won't
they just won't go below because and I find
that most companies that want longer terms
the reason they want longer terms or a couple one
is they have these big libraries and they want if
new ways to release films come out on the market
they want to have this huge library of films that
they can monetize that new way so for instance
advertising video and demand or AVOD is relatively
new platform so all these companies that had
all these movies suddenly had a whole nother
way to monetizing these films and if they had only
had three years there'd be four or five years of
films that they didn't have to put through this
these platforms another reason is it looks better
on your books to have long terms so if someone's
evaluating of a bank is evaluating your company
if you're trying to sell it to someone
and you have 20 films for three years
they're like well geez in three years you this is
nothing like so and if and you're not going to be
able to monetize it with a new platform that comes
around like like if avod or something like it
so their assets on the books of these Bank of
these companies the banks just value them more
if they have longer terms on their contracts
interesting and is it reasonable to expect
the longer the terms of the contract the more
or the possibility of an advance no not really
well I should say maybe the the companies that are
doing three years are not doing advances yeah so I
guess I guess yes is actually the answer to that
question so the companies are doing 7 10 15 years
are more likely to do advances and I think that's
I think that's because they just don't have to be
as aggressive as the three-year they're usually
offering a little bit more than the companies that
are doing three years they have a longer they've
been around longer they might be doing theatrical
on some of their movies they just have bigger
pipeline yeah they're a little bit more they're
not having to be as aggressive to get films than
the companies that are doing the three-year terms
movies that I've watched on TV these were all
films that have been out for 20 plus years so
yeah that makes sense yeah it would be the case
for wanting them to on their I don't know they
want them on their books but establish names from
filmmakers that have been around yeah exactly why
does slam dance co-founder and filmmaker
Dan mervish call you a shrewd negotiator
um because I paid him okay all right that's
good I Dan's a great friend I I met him early
on in the in the days of slam dance because
I think I attended the second slam dance
and been going ever since and I've had every
year I have two to four movies at slam dance
and then at some point it struck up a friendship
with Dan's been so long I don't remember when
and then I remember even when he when
he was going around with his second film
I read it gave him some comments on it I don't
think anything to do with that one and then later
on I've sold a couple I've sold now two films
for him and kind of consulted him on another one
and and Dan's a very Dan is a little much more
knowledgeable than your average Indie filmmaker
so he's definitely a big part of the process
when I'm helping when I when I have helped
him sell a film and and so there's a
shorthand there too and so I think he
I think more than anybody he knows a little
bit more than my average client what I know
and how helpful I can be and so like like
I said there are some people like Dan Dan
could probably take the time and do what
I do and get everybody to watch the film
it might it might take longer because he he's not
doing it year round like I am and I think that's
why any and because I stare at it I know all
these things he knows by experience what I know
and and yeah then it comes in negotiation
that's fun because it's we we go back and forth in
terms of like how we're going to try to influence
the buyer that he likes to do do the best by it
so how do you negotiate the best deal for a movie
well to a certain degree I I think that
most films I'm working on are going to this
certain level of distributor and there's only a
certain range that we're going to be negotiating
and I already know going in what the
best position that these negotiations
will do for really any film if it hits
that range so there's some films where
um I just know exactly where they'll go
I know where they won't go and it's it's
more about communicating the filmmaker like
you hear your hear your options here's how
we can kind of push a little bit or pull a
little bit it does get more interesting when
it's a it's a it gets above that level and we're
getting theatrical offered and and I I find that
it's best to go to Distributors with the position
of hey they really want to be with you but here's
what you got to do I'm not a fan of like saying
well so and so wants it are you going to beat them
I'm not a fan of um telling people what we
want upfront usually if it Disturbia comes to
me and says well what do you want I'm saying
I usually say we want the best possible deal
because I don't want to undersell it I want
them to come to me with the best possible thing
there's a little bit of that I guess I've been
doing it so much and so I I don't find it that
complicated a lot of it's intuitive and a
lot of it's just knowing knowing who I'm
dealing with pretty well and and knowing
where they'll go and where they won't
so you're not trying any well if you don't let
us know in five days I have X Y and Z over here
that they want it and you'd be crazy to lose
out in this doesn't work yeah it just doesn't
[Music] and especially since I'm I mean maybe
if I was just a one-off person that they didn't
know me and had no history of dealing with
me but almost everybody I'm selling films
to I've sold two films for a couple decades
so it's there's it's there's it's a lot more
it's a lot more straightforward and like like
this is really the I also know since I know where
they'll potentially go I know where they won't go
I know not to go to them with something crazy that
they won't do and I have it in situations where
filmmaker is like well push them anyway like hey
they won't pay in advance but ask for one anyway
and I'll do it I don't care but I'm always right
I mean they're they're not going to they're not
going to do what I know they're not going to do
I don't think I've ever been surprised that way
another rule of thumb there is that if someone's
if someone's made an advance offer an mg offer
then they're probably movable on it a little bit
if if but not not a hundred percent greater than
what they've offered so they've offered you twenty
thousand they're probably not going to 40. they
might go to 25 or 30. that that's a generalization
if they offered nothing they're probably not
offering anything they're probably not moving
even to one thousand dollars because that's
just not the way they see it this transaction
so it's just knowing those things I think that
helps the negotiation so you you pretty much know
the rules of the game the players in the game
and where those films are going to plug in and
there's probably not a lot of leeway like you
said if someone's not going to give a minimum
guarantee they're probably not going to do a
thousand or Twenty Thousand for one right exactly
that's not to say I am surprised by who
wants what though and it's not like I like
I'm I'm selling the film right now to HBO I
didn't know HBO was going to want the movie
or pay a good license fee for it I had no idea and
my my next best offer was not even close to what
they offered so it's not that I know it's going to
happen I just know once they make the offer I know
I know where where they'll go where they won't go
how often are these negotiations in person and how
often are they via email Skype yeah they're all
a combination of zoom and and email and phone
even pre-covered overwhelmingly unless you're
selling film at Sundance they were selling a
film with Sundance or South by Southwest
and it's in person then you're going to
a condo and you're meeting meeting people
in person if there have been times though I
guess there are occasions though where I have had
filmmakers go to meet distributors in Los Angeles
as part of the process pre-covid but I don't need
to be there because I'm just putting them together
to meet in order to talk creative and what they
do for the film and then the negotiation will
happen by phone or or by email afterwards because
so much of it needs to be in writing yeah there's
just no reason to get together like there's no
reason to get in a car and drive 30 minutes to
just do what you can do pretty more efficiently
by by phone or email can you explain the deal memo
Dillman was a turn sheet at the end of the
day so Dil memo is the basic terms of a deal
the term the length of the the contract the
minimum guarantee if they're going to pay
something up front for the movie The number
of years the rights they're going to take and
then some of the other factors that they every
demo is a little bit or term sheets a little bit
different in terms of what they'll they'll put out
there in terms of what they are the it's kind of
a it's like you said earlier Cliff Notes version
of the contract okay sorry I didn't realize the
deal number was the same thing yeah it's a
term okay maybe you said that okay without
naming names what's the worst distribution deal
you've seen a distributor offer one of your films
um question
um well certainly not one that I ever would allow
someone to take it usually when I see a bad one
it has to do with how revenues are shared and
they're just the Distributors just taking too much
um there are some deals where there's
some Distributors out there that use
other Distributors to get their
films out into the marketplace
um and so they're taking a percentage after the
distributor who's doing the work is taking a
percentage after iTunes has taken a percentage
right so I went from iTunes to distributor to
distributor to you and some Distributors small
these are smaller companies don't disclose it
and say Hey this is our distribution fee but just
so we're also going through this other company
there are companies though that do legitimately
and say okay this is our distribution fee and
it's inclusive of the distribution company that is
actually doing the work that getting it out there
or they'll say it is on top of and yes it's a
big fee but but that's what we that's the way
we do it this is a little bit more legitimate
than hiding it right so the worst deal is is
the combination of the fact that it's fee on top
of a fee and they're not revealing they're just
going to give you a royalty statement that says
what came in and what they took from it without
explaining that another level of Revenue went from
one person to another person that came to them
if that makes sense why would a filmmaker even
I mean why would a company even think that
a filmmaker would entertain it's like an extra
middle man that's not just a middle man it sounds
like a well again some people don't reveal it and
they don't know that's the familiar doesn't know
that's the question right and okay there I do know
one company that will reveal it if you ask them
but they don't reveal it if they don't if you
don't ask them which and it's just really strange
because I like without naming names I like a
lot of things about these people they're really
they do other things kind of right but that one
aspect of it I like why why like and I guess it's
because probably because they're not winning
movies because they have to re that when they
do reveal that some filmers are like well I can't
give you a percentage on top of another percentage
and I know another company though that what they
figured out to do is to make the company that they
go through have their fee inclusive of their fee
so the fee that they're proffering it might be
more like 30 35 because they're having to account
for giving 15 to someone else but at least
it's it's more competitive than charging 25
on top of 20. right so you do get different
kinds out there but overwhelmingly most
of my films all almost all of my films
almost 100 go through companies that
there's just one fee being paid taken out
there's there's one distributor I go through who
takes a fee but has it inclusive of this company
he's going through and he's a he's an honorable X
Studio guy who was very straightforward about what
he does and essentially the way the the conundrum
the Distributors that people have when they become
a dis they want to become a distributor is how do
I get to Market right because anybody I could go
tomorrow and say hey I'm a distributor you give
me the movie and I go put it on iTunes through a
lab I just pay the encoding fee real easy what's
harder is to sell it to cable VOD and to establish
a distribution relationship with the streamers
and established relationship with Tubi and the
other advertising video on demand companies that's
harder to do and so what some people decide is hey
I want to distribute movies but I don't have those
relationships I'll create a partnership with a
bigger company I'll go to the cost of acquiring
and marketing the movies and we'll just have a
relationship with this company where they are the
ones who put it on the platforms and do the sales
and that's fine if you're above board about it
and your fee isn't too and you're able to do a
fee structure that that doesn't take too much out
of the dollar but if it's if you don't reveal it
quasi-criminal to me it's not criminal
but it's very unethical and um
and then and then just the fee structure is just
crazy like if you do a fee on top of fee it's
just like how do you how do you make any money
it's very hard so if a filmmaker was doing the
DIY wearing the distribution hat themselves and
and they've been approached or they approached
someone and they don't realize this is not that
there's not just one Phoebe how are they going to
uncover that what kind of clues or paper trail
or how are they going to do a search to see so
some platforms like Amazon and others have in
the details of the film they'll have like the
copyright date and a little bit of information
and some of them have the distributor name
and so if the distributor isn't your distributor
most likely they put it through somebody else oh
wow right but that would be too late at that point
oh yeah yeah yeah there's a there's a there are
definitely a lot of there are a lot of companies
that just don't do it properly one way or another
um and I just don't send them my movies it's
showing me easily easily handled that way sure
it's real fun it's sort of this omitting very
important information yeah interesting so that
it would be very difficult until you get to
a point where you can't even get out of the
contract it sounds like yeah I mean like I said
like distribution contracts are hard to get out of
they're not they're not built to be
easy to get out of and especially if
you're working with someone who didn't tell you
everything up front about how they do business
most likely they don't really
care if you want to get out either
right that's the kind of person they
are so that's why it's very important
if if you are diying it if you are going to
distributors or producer reps or anybody you
should be checking IMDb and calling those
filmmakers and and trying to get enough of
them to tell you what their experiences were so
that you can make a a little bit of an educated
decision on on where to go sure and even in
doing that you can still run into problems
100 so people know each other they could be
friends they could have alliances yeah it's real
tricky but yeah that's interesting I I did not
know that yeah for for filmmakers that because in
that that there's a bigger chunk being taken out
because there's this extra person that's right.